I've spoken to you before about different
ways in which the world really has been laughing
at us for a long time since Donald Trump became
president.
They laughed when we elected a president who
thinks climate change is a Chinese hoax.
They laughed that we elected a president who
has no idea how economics or currency or trade
or medicine or the constitution or the law
or public transit or any of it works.
And they were laughing at us early during
the Corona virus pandemic.
And even as recently as a couple of weeks
ago, many countries were laughing at us.
I showed you about 10 days ago articles from
all over the world, the Netherlands, South
Africa, Peru, everywhere, ridiculing our moronic
president for his comments about bleach, injections
and the other things he said during that press
briefing.
But they're not really laughing anymore.
Now it has gone from laughter to concern to
actual pity.
The emails I have gotten over the last few
days from our international viewers, people
that used to be poking fun at Trump's idiotic
claims about vaccines and the virus, they
now write to me and say, David, we feel sorry
for you that you were dealing with this in
the United States.
We feel sorry that you are in a situation
where no matter what you do, even if you do
the right things, even if you have the best
intentions and the accurate understanding
of what it is that's going on and what it
is that's necessary to deal with this virus,
we feel sorry for you because your federal
government has failed.
They are incompetent.
There is no plan.
There is just a series of lies and disinformation
and confusion and bogus talking points.
And there are even Republicans who are willing
to tell the truth.
They are increasingly agreeing this is just
some Republicans.
Of course, most of them are actually behind
Donald Trump.
Check out Republican strategist Steve Schmidt
explaining it again.
This is a lifelong Republican strategists.
Take it.
Take a look.
Donald Trump has been the worst president
this country has ever had.
And I don't say that hyperbolic heat here.
But here's a consequential president.
And he has brought this country in three short
years to a place of weakness that is simply
unimaginable.
If you were pondering where we are today from
the day where Barack Obama left office and
there were a lot of us on that day who were
deeply skeptical and very worried about what
a Trump presidency would be.
But this is a moment of unparalleled national
humiliation, of weakness.
When you listen to the president, these are
the musings of an imbecile, an idiot.
And I don't use those words.
The name call, I use them because they're
the precise words in the English language
to describe his behavior, his comportment,
his actions.
We've never seen a level of incompetence,
a level of ineptitude so staggering on a daily
basis by anybody in the history of the country
whose ever been charged with substantial responsibility.
Steve Schmidt, Schmidt is sadly absolutely
right.
The presidency is deadly.
And as more and more countries open up, it
is us people in the United States who won't
be allowed to fly into other countries because
we are a mess here as other countries are
actually dealing with the problem as Trump
talks about a super duper missile.
We'll get to that later.
That's actually a phrase that he used.
His son goes on TV and says it's all going
to disappear on Election Day because it's
merely a fake political scandal by Democrats.
As that goes on here, the world is taking
pity on us for our failed leadership.
I was trying over the weekend to think of
an analogy to try to apply to this, because
there are people who are analyzing this administration
as if it were a normal administration.
You have these people, some of whom are so-called
enlightened centrists, who pretend to see
both sides and find things they like and Trump
and things that they dislike.
You can't evaluate this president like you
can other presidents.
Here's an analogy I thought of that I'm workshopping
and I want to try out on you.
When someone says about Trump, well, you know,
he has an unusual way of talking about the
issues.
But he's right on de-regulation and he's right
on trade.
But maybe he's not the best guy on Corona
virus.
Imagine.
OK, this is the analogy.
Imagine I was playing in a chess tournament
and I show up and I replace all the queen,
the pawns on the board with Queens that I
take out of my pocket before the game starts.
That's insane.
And it's simultaneously making a mockery of
the tournament.
It's also cheating.
I'm also either an idiot or a bad person for
doing it.
Imagine that a chess commentator sees me take
eight queens out of my pocket and put him
on the board instead of the pawns and says,
you know, David, strategy is unusual, but
it's certainly an aggressive way to play the
game.
What?
No.
That doesn't make sense.
Yeah.
I mean, some players use the Spanish opening
and others take Queens out of their pocket
and replace the ponds.
We're not talking about the same thing here.
So when these enlightened centrists and pragmatic
conservatives and whoever else, when they
pretend to do an analysis of Donald Trump's
presidency as if it were even remotely normal,
they're failing the sniff test on principle.
But there's another issue here, with very
few exceptions in the Republican Party.
They are mostly just enabling this.
There are a few Republicans who have taken
a stand and are saying this can't happen.
Right.
You've got people like Mitt Romney, who's
a current senator from Utah, Republican.
You have George Conway, a lifelong Republican.
Steve Schmidt, lifelong Republican strategist.
There are a few other Republicans I can't
name them all, who have not softened their
view on Trump.
And they are straight up saying this is not
acceptable.
This is not normal.
This can't be dealt with in normal terms because
normal terms don't apply.
I'm not talking about them.
But for the most part, Republicans in Congress,
in the House and Senate have enabled this.
Most Republican governors have enabled this.
So Trump is not alone to blame here.
We have to blame the sixty three million Americans
that voted for Donald Trump.
Yes, they are to blame.
It doesn't matter whether you call them bad
people or stupid or they are to blame.
Their actions are to blame for what we are
dealing with right now.
Of course, Trump is to blame.
But the Republican Party, that mostly continues
to enable him that even before the impeachment
trial had already decided were voting to acquit
Donald Trump on impeachment charges.
They have to be held accountable as well.
We have the opportunity to hold every single
one of the Republicans in the House accountable
in November.
We have an opportunity to hold the Republicans
that are up for reelection in the Senate in
November, which is of the 34 up for reelection.
I forget the exact number of Republicans,
but a number of Republicans are up for reelection
in November.
They have to be held accountable
as well.